[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et passe à 24 heures d'écart à tout
public et
on n'a qu'à white
mékong en asie
titine avec nous ce soir non je peux pas
j'ai un rendez-vous qui avec la patronne
de l'hôtel
je peux pas lui poser un lapin ça serait
dur à la tellement insisté et puis en
plus je sens que ce soir je vais
conclure tu m'aides pas non pas la non
vie qui me sidère jean-claude ça fait
toujours que la caisse est déjà sur un
coup coûte bernard je crois que toi et
moi on a un peu le même problème c'est à
dire qu'on peut pas vraiment tout miser
sur notre physique surtout toi si je
peux me permettre de donner un conseil
c'est oublier que t'as aucune chance
vas-y fonce on sait jamais sur un
malentendu ça peut marcher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
six heures qu'on joue c'est bon j'ai un
deux trois feuilles
proposions un deux trois frères
ils ont forcément
you'll
be continued
partie du monde où ils sont
minces me commande de
l'atteinte huchon
ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]